today we are checking out a brand new
coffee maker this makes coffee in an all
new way it's called spin
this is something that has been in
development for many years it started
out as a kickstarter and now over five
years later it is finally shipping to
customers and what's exciting about this
is they have perfected an all-new way of
making coffee let's check it out and
i'll show you guys why this is so unique
this has an accompanying app so in the
app not only can i decide what type of
coffee i want to make but it also has a
marketplace right now this coffee
marketplace has over 1500 different bags
of coffee from over 450 local roasters
this allows you to set up a subscription
there's also a little quiz that will ask
you what type of coffee you like and
then those beans will be automatically
shipped to you if you choose to have a
subscription and also even if you don't
have this machine you guys can still
have access to the marketplace to order
really great coffee i have a few of
these here that i've ordered already
there's another thing that makes the app
really cool this has coffee bean
recognition so when you take a picture
of the front of the coffee
it will be able to find this in the
marketplace and it will also be able to
link it up to your app so that the
coffee machine knows the type of coffee
that you're about to make and it will
use different algorithms to grind the
beans a different way use different
temperatures of water all of those
things are determined in advance by the
roasters so the type of coffee that this
will make is exactly what they had in
mind now it's time to make some coffee
first i'm going to make an espresso and
we're going to use these beans because i
already opened these ones
oh it smells so good honestly there's
nothing better than just smelling fresh
coffee beans
another thing that's important when
you're making good coffee is having good
filtered water so a built-in filter
let's fill it up
that's it now it's giving me the option
to choose my coffee and we already have
our blueprint seasonal house coffee
already in here so i'm gonna click
select this little reservoir is great
because you can just keep the beans in
here they're ready to go and it doesn't
grind it until you're ready to make an
espresso or a coffee and now it's time
for espresso i already know it's gonna
be good because i've already made one
before but we're gonna make one here for
you guys are you ready i'm ready
espresso go
why this is called spin is because
the beans are actually spinning inside
of this machine instead of being pressed
down
it smells so good
my entire house now just smells like a
coffee shop so it goes through this
whole process it makes your espresso and
it also cleans the machine at the same
time so it's forcing those grinds into
this little area right down here and
makes it super easy to clean we don't
need to talk about cleaning right now
we're talking about espresso
i mean it looks perfect
but how does it taste
it's so smooth i've tried a lot of
coffee from so many different types of
machines like this and what makes this
so good is the fact that these beans are
being ground right here and they're so
fresh and this is so smooth
gonna be so hyped up it's so good what
would you like what's your coffee wanna
make a coffee tyler has ordered a coffee
here at the barista bar of my kitchen
that guy here
there you go there's also an option here
to customize the drink so you can adjust
the coffee strength the water level and
also the speed so this is great because
if you do want a cup of coffee that's a
little bit stronger you have that option
we're just gonna stick to the basics
let's click make drink it's for you
tyler
[Music]
tyler's coffee's ready
there you go there you go
it's really hot you might want to wait a
second
oh
i saw a smile whoa isn't it good yeah
it's so smooth like it's just i can't
even get over the fact that it's just
it's so fresh
oh man now let's make a latte for my
sister jenna so this is one of their
milk frothers this doesn't come with the
coffee machine but this is an added
extra this will allow you to make more
cappuccino or if you just want some more
milk
you can also warm up some milk with that
so
whatever you're into
milk hey jenna what kind of milk you
want i i like all milk except almond
milk doesn't like me okay hold that yeah
that's pretty good that's all cool milk
that is a lot of milk i put this on
the milk is being frothed this is like
the future ah i'm aware now we're gonna
make you an espresso all the milk is
frothing i do it just pour some beans in
there it doesn't matter how many i put
in i mean you can put them all in there
because this top will keep them fresh
but this will be just the type of pocket
you'll be drinking for a while okay that
makes sense it's good though it smells
so good i know
[Music]
it's real cute
oh
and your espresso is done
that looks good okay so you're gonna
dump it into here okay
[Music]
oh i'll get a mess i'll work on that
okay pouring skills oh look at that it's
gone nothing happened our milk is
frothed are you ready are you ready i
don't know let's see your barista skills
oh
[Music]
look at that
now let's add a little foamy foam to the
top oh my gosh yeah i know this is
incredible i'm aware okay that's enough
oh you don't want any more foam how am i
gonna get to the good wait i need to get
you a little cinnamon when are you gonna
learn how to make some designs look how
beautiful that is okay
i have it yeah but we gotta get the shop
first
okay here we go so good i put a lot of
foam i'm sorry you're gonna get that all
over you
mm-hmm
oh
mm-hmm can i try oh um
okay can maybe i can have a little
on the other side yeah okay it's really
really good oh that's incredible
actually this is actually really
very good this is my first latte i made
well do you want it then okay
[Music]
this is so awesome what i love about
this so much is also very easy to clean
check this out this is where all of the
excess grounds whoa
i know where'd they hide them and it
squeezes out all the excess water so you
don't have to worry about these being
like all gross it's all dry so dry dump
it out rinse it out and you're done well
this is the first look at the spin
coffee maker i'm such a huge fan of this
and i cannot wait to make more coffee
one of the things to note is if you do
order it now they do have a backlog of
pre-orders that they have to ship out
first so if you do order it now you
wouldn't get one until later on this
year but either way this is so exciting
and a huge step forward for making
coffee at home thank you so much for
watching let me know what you guys think
of this and let me know in the comments
below what your favorite type of coffee
is i will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]